so in the last video we talked about the
henderson-hasselbalch equation and we
talked about how it would be useful in
biochemistry now why is this equation
useful for us or useful to us in
biochemistry oops let me underline this
to kind of separate it away notice here
and when I wrote it last time I wrote it
as a minus over H a and I want to talk
about that really briefly just as a
review we talked about how the pH equals
PKA plus the log of the conjugate base
over the acid now specifically when we
talked about that we we mentioned this
classical reaction right if we had an
acid it would dissociate into its proton
and its anion right so we mentioned that
we mentioned that we called this this is
obviously the acid here this H a an acid
is a proton donor so it don't is its
proton this here and it is left to exist
as this anion here which is we should
call the conjugate base right I know I'm
not writing out conjugate forgive me for
that but I'm just trying to save space
and time any case this is the conjugate
base and this is the asteroid we've
established that before and you probably
already know that from G chem so the
henderson-hasselbalch equation what it
allows us to do is it allows us to if we
know the pKa of a particular acid right
which describes an acid strength more
about that later if we know the pH as
well then we can determine what the base
acid ratio is and what that really means
is that if we know that if we know the
pKa that was just a particular acid and
we know the pH of the environment of the
acid environment of the acid or of a
solution that the acid is in then we
should be able to determine how much of
that axe acid actually exists in this
form its protonated form right carrying
that proton versus how much is in the
conjugate base for how much exists as
this anion
so here when we find this essentially
this based acid ratio I could rewrite
this here just has a little note is that
when we talk about the base to acid
ratio all right that's going to be equal
to like this whole idea here this anion
over H a now I'm take this with a grain
of salt and the reason why I say that is
because it's not always the case that
the conjugate base is an anion and I'll
explain more of that later
but what I want to do here briefly just
as an introduction I want to do a quick
example problem with the henderson
hasselbalch equation just so we can kind
of learn how to work it so let's do a
quick problem so if we know actually I
write this in white so if if we're told
that the pKa of a particular functional
group right is 9 okay and it's at a pH
to the solution which pH is equal to 5
right what is what's the base to acid
ratio okay
now we're going not going to apply this
specifically to a particular function of
your brain just yet
I kind of want to just to just go
through the math really quickly and get
an idea of how that works and then once
we once we get the math then we'll go
ahead and do some more explanation ok so
if we know this we have the pKa is equal
to 9 and pH is 5 all we really to do is
plug that into the equation and figure
out the answer so if we have a pH of 5
or plug that in a pH of 5 and equal pKa
of 9 plus the log of the base of the
acid base over acid okay so this is what
we have so far so given that
we want we want this ratio here okay so
obviously what we're going to do is try
to get this this log
it's log base over acid by itself so
we're going to do is we're going to take
we're going to take this this nine
objects just practice it over to the
other side and when we do that we're
going to a negative four equals the log
of the concentration of the base over
the concentration of the acid so now we
want just this value we don't want the
log of this value so if you recall from
you know math from back in the day scary
how much math is involved with all this
stuff in order to undo a log or to get
rid of a law we take the base 10 of the
log so if we're gonna take the base 10
of this log and then we're going to take
the base 10 of this other side right
whatever do to one side or the other I
mean that's algebra right so we take the
base 10 here okay so the base 10 of
negative 4 and base 10 of this log of
the base over the acid so when we do
that that undoes this log right or these
uh these undo each other because they're
inverses right and then we get 10 to the
negative 4 is equal to the base with the
acid concentration so so now if you plug
in 10 to the 4 of your calculator you'll
probably get some sort of decimal number
right one time send a negative or so but
what I want to do is I don't want to get
I don't want to express this value this
base over acid ratio I don't want to I
don't want to express it as a decimal
value the reason why is because I want
to know for every you know one base how
many acid form how many are in the acid
form so if you think of 10 to the
negative 4 what you essentially what
that value is is 1 over 10,000 right one
with 4 zeros that's obviously equal to
immediate what is it Oh point zero zero
zero
one eye whatever it is but if you put
that into your calculator you will get
the decimal value but if you expressed
it as a fraction like this then what
this is basically telling you is that
for every one into every one species in
the base form you will have 10,000 in
the acid form given that the pKa of your
acid is is 9 and the pH of the
environment is 5 now we're going to talk
about why that makes sense in just a
second ok so let me just repeat that
with you quickly so basically what this
means is that if we had if we're
assuming that this case right for
assuming this case then our conjugate
base is the a minus right so this means
that if we have this going on here then
that's the conjugate base and the acid
is DHA
so for everyone and I only have we have
10,000 protonated acid right ok so what
basically what this tells us is where
this allows us to do we relate we're
going to talk about amino acids and what
we're talking about in class is a lot
but we're going to be interested in what
a particular amino acid looks like at a
given pH if we already know the pKa of
the functional groups so more on that
later obviously in future videos but
that's why this is going to be useful ok
so let's talk about why why this even
makes sense ok so um let's let's change
this color back to white ok so now um
what we talked about earlier briefly all
that we talked about we talked about it
briefly we talked about what PKA sort of
describes now what I want you to do is I
want you to think about PKA whenever you
think about PKA I want you to think
specifically that this value tells us
about the acid strength okay
now if you recall um a lower PKA right
change this color a lower PKA a lower
PKA that stronger or weaker acid if you
remember hopefully some of you answered
that that question just a moment ago a
lower PKA is a stronger acid alright so
if a PKA is lower we have a stronger
acid now remember how I wanted you to
think about the definition of an acid
being a proton donor I really want you
to keep that in mind so if an acid is a
strong acid it's going to be a very good
proton donor and if it's a very good
proton donor what does that mean that
means it's going to donate its proton if
so if this acid donates its proton this
proton will be free then what will what
form will that particular functional
group exist in well if it's doing its
its proton its protons free-floating
then it has to be in its conjugate base
form so when we have a lower PKA we are
talking about a stronger acid then that
stronger acid will most likely exist in
its conjugate base form okay I'm right
here
more will exist in its conjugate base
form so more will exist in conjugate
base form okay now the converse is true
right if you have a larger PKA value you
means you'll have a weaker acid and if
an acid is weak right that means it's
not as good a proton donor so it's not
going to be willing to give up its
proton right this if this is the acid
and it's a weak acid then n it has a
high PK then this being a weak acid it's
not going to want to give up its proton
so it's not going to dissociate into
these two components what it's going to
do it's going to stay pronated so more
will exist in the acid form okay so now
what about pH why do we why do we care
about pH all right even consider pH so
what I keep this in mind for now PKA
tells us acid strength
okay what about pH what is pH do so pH
it tells us or it describes the
environment okay or describe the acidity
or basicity of the environment so
describes environment right acidity or
basicity right I'm sure you guys have
all heard of this you know the whole
idea that you know if the lower the pH
the more acidic something is right if we
have like you know lemon juices is
acidic you know water is neutral and you
know Clorox bleach is basic all that
sort of stuff right but essentially if
you remember if you remember from pH
just talking about pH in general
chemistry you should remember that a
lower pH what does that tell you a lower
pH described means that there's a higher
proton concentration right and if
there's a higher proton concentration
that is considered to be an acidic
environment okay and of course the
opposite is true if you have a higher pH
right you have a lower H+ concentration
and that means you have a basic
environment okay so I'm boring you all
with this aren't I
that is very very ugly the way I wrote
environment sorry about that
but that does say environment hopefully
and what I want you to keep in mind is
that when I when I say all these things
these these pH is they're always
relative to something else actually
PKA values right if for both of these
ideas right I'm a right here relative
okay and the reason why is because if
you're comparing um if you're these are
relative values if you have two acids
and they both have pk's I have that PK's
if their assets right so if you know one
ad over both pk's you can tell me which
acid is stronger given its PKA on the
flip side if you're given to two
solutions and you have two ph's then you
can tell me which at which environment
is more acidic or more basic based on
that right so now what's cool about the
henderson hasselbalch equation is it
kind of allows us to consider both of
these variables and how that affects the
functional group and what it will look
like so now i'm going to talk about what
what the Henderson house about equation
predicts mathematically but how to think
about it qualitatively so what we're
going to do here is what happens okay
let's let's kind of like separate this
we're going bottom about two right here
right from everything else so what I
want to talk about now is what happens
when the pKa what should you expect when
the pKa is is less than the pH who just
did a practice problem here we said if
the pKa here is nine a pH is five what's
the base odds ratio so we found that
more base assuming excuse me not more
base there was one base for every 10,000
acid that means more acid right here
than then that base so we're going to
kind of explain that with qualitatively
now remember I mentioned I mentioned
that the pKa describes the acid right
and the pH describes the environment
right which I'm just going to I'm just
going to write the whole thing okay
pH describes the environment so if the
pKa is less than the pH what can we
conclude
okay so we conclude conclude here that
if the pka smaller than the the pH the
environment are the environment that's
very ugly I'm really sorry the
environment is basic right basic
relative to the acid group the
functional group right again I'm using
the term relative here
I don't know right ask the group
actually that's my right functional
group obviously it's particularly an
acid but I don't want to get everyone
confused okay relative to the functional
group right which is obviously can be an
acid if it has a PKA so what does that
mean if something if the environment is
basic relative to the functional group
right because its value is bigger than
the pKa right what that means excuse me
is that in the environment the
environment has a proton deficiency what
does that mean okay so if there's if
this is it basically implying that the
pH is high relative to the pKa over here
is a moment ago we said if there's a
high pH the low H+ concentration that's
a basic environment so there's a proton
deficiency in the environment so what
does that mean why do we care about that
so so if the protis a proton deficiency
in the environment that means the acid
will donate protons to the environment
right the functional group will donate
protons to the environment I'm just
going to abbreviate that there okay so
what does that mean alright if the acid
functional group will donate its proton
to the environment that means it's
acting as an acid right so if it donates
its proton what form would be expected
to be in well first of all it'll be
deprotonated right
that simply means that it lost its
proton right so if it's deprotonated
that means it's going to exist in
conjugate base form okay another way to
say that is that the conjugate base form
will predominate okay now what if the
opposite is true what if what if what if
the pKa was greater than the pH if the
pKa is greater than the pH well then
what happens well now now the pH is
lower than the pKa so the environment
right is it going to be basic or acidic
relative to the pKa or the acid group
the environment will be acidic right a
lower pH describes an acidic environment
so the environment is acidic relative to
the functional group so the environment
is acidic relative to the functional
group right so if it's an acidic
environment there's a proton surplus so
if it's a pro
on surplus in the environment this means
that so the functional group so if
there's a surplus of protons in the
environment it's likely that the
functional group will pick up a proton
or accept the proton from the
environment right so it will be
protonated right will pick up a proton
so it's gonna be protonated it'll exist
in its acid form okay now what if the
pKa is equal to the pH whew what happens
then if the pKa is equal to the pH well
that's that's going to be kind of funny
right because now neither one the pH
right describing the environment the the
environment is not acidic or basic
relative to the functional group so what
happens here when the pKa is equal to
the pH we have 50% oh goodness
50% will exist in the base form
conjugate base form and 50% will exist
in the acid form right essentially the
amount in the base form will equal the
amount in the acid form now how do you
kind of explain that with the henderson
hasselbalch equation well let's just do
that really briefly and that will be the
last thing we include in this video so
if you think about this over here right
over here if the pKa eat oops sorry
about that I meant to write pH first
so if the pH equals the pKa plus the log
of the concentration of the base over
the concentration of the acid right if
the concentration of the base equals the
concentration of the acid then there if
they're equal then I can basically
rewrite that as this write that as pH
equals PKA I can just replace one with
the other right if if if the base
conservation of base equals the
concentration of acid then I can just
say that this is equal to the log of the
concentration of the acid over a lot of
the concentration over the acid right
because they're equal values essentially
this value is one right maybe you didn't
need me to write that to realize that
but this value right is equal to one or
should be oops choose some just all over
the place today this value here is equal
to one so then what we get is the pH
equals the pKa plus the log of one now
if you guys remember again back to back
to math again the graph for log looks a
little like this looks like this log of
X looks something like this right where
the log of one is at the x-intercept so
this value of log of one right
equals zero so essentially what we have
is the pH will equal the pKa right so
this is we just mathematically suggested
that at the win the pH when the pH
equals the pKa well here we talked about
how the pKa being equal to the pH means
that 50% will exist in the base form 50%
will exist in the acid form excuse me
and then the equation we said that if
the base form equal if we have this the
equal concentrations of base and acid
then we'll find the pH will equal the
pKa
that'll be the end of this video I hope
that was helpful
this stuff will be very very very useful
when we talk about amino acids in their
functional groups and what what they
will look like a particular constant
excuse me a particular pH is pH at based
on their PKS
so the future videos will have some
examples about this sort of stuff and
hopefully as we go along they'll make
more and more sense thanks for watching